emails are arguably still the most
important medium of professional
communication in most corporates the
writing a strong email is not easy it's
really a craft a skill that needs to be
trained and developed and practiced so
welcome to another coffee break here on
my channel from learning i'm a former
mckinsey consultant and on my channel i
want to help you to become successful in
the first years of your career and today
i want to talk about writing effective
and well-structured remates so without
further ado let's jump into it i
prepared an email here as a practical
example that now we can together improve
let me briefly read out the email to you
subject summary of kickoff dear team
thank you for your time last week in the
kickoff looking forward to meet you
again in our first dro fix next tuesday
paul can you please schedule it and also
our monthly still costs i very much
enjoyed our discussion on what
initiatives to focus on for the new
markets project we decided to not
further pursue opportunities in the
nordics or eastern europe we agreed to
focus on spain for a pilot for cavic
product line gold 20 euro million
revenue in six months we also need to
conduct consumer focus groups in germany
to develop new product variations at the
end of the year in addition we want to
reduce our engagement in the french
market we therefore want to close down
our state's offices but make sure the
key accounts can still be served from
our european account managers as the
first step i suggest we structure all
these initiatives into project plan
carla can you please set one up for
first your fix next week please everyone
who better prepare for joe fix meetings
i expect to receive regular updates from
the sales marketing and product team
leads in these meetings let's make sure
we are able to provide meaningful
updates to our board in the monthly
stickers thanks everyone best luis so
while this email is not completely
horrible there are for sure several
things that can be improved
significantly and the first is the
subject line so here it says summary of
kickoff well that's not wrong but of
course it's quite generic as a
professional you might deal with
different projects at the same time it's
always better to be a little bit more
precise more specific that you directly
have the context of such an email in the
inbox so maybe rather write something
like project new markets summary kickoff
just to provide this context let's now
talk about the first paragraph of your
email here you should make sure to
always have two things included first
provide some context what is this about
what is the context of what you're
writing in and then second also try to
summarize what exactly you want so if
you want to schedule a meeting with
someone don't just write this in the
last sentence of the email but write
this in the first paragraph this is also
the idea of top-down communication if
you have no idea what top-down
communication is i made a video about
that in the past as well i will link it
somewhere about here and in this example
probably would make sense just to
provide an outline of what you will do
here so you will summarize what has
happened in the kickoff and what the key
topics are that you will write about
again this provides important context
another person knows what to expect when
looking at the rest of the email so
let's next talk about the structure of
an email the core of every good email is
a good structure notice how here the
email is structured in different
paragraphs but these paragraphs do not
seem to follow any logical organization
principle the next paragraph talks about
initiatives first it mentions things
that the team does not want to focus on
the nordics or eastern europe and then
it talks about an initiative that the
team does want to focus on here's spain
for a pilot the third paragraph once
again talks about initiatives first
about what is supposed to happen in
germany then what is supposed to happen
in france and then it is mixed with
information on to-dos and then the last
paragraph again talks about your fixed
meetings the expectations toward these
meetings and then also some info on the
monthly steer course that are apparently
supposed to take place so let's go over
different things that can be improved
here and first let's think about the
logical groups the logical categories
that you want to talk about so in this
email the three types of information
apparent that the person wants to
communicate first the focus initiatives
that are supposed to happen second the
meeting schedule what types of meetings
are supposed to take place and then
third the next steps what are the two
do's that the team members have and when
coming up with these logical categories
always think of the mesi principle that
is of course also applicable here as
well when coming up with these groups
and if you have no idea what the mise
principle is it's a structure principle
that is very commonly used in consulting
in professional services i made a video
about that in the past i will link it
somewhere but here check it out a little
more next try to use bullet point format
whenever possible avoid writing long
sentences like you would write
paragraphs in a book you need far more
words to say the very same things take
out words by using bullet point format
and that again makes it far easier to
process for the person reading this
another little technique that you can
use just to increase the clarity and
provide more structure of your email is
to go beyond just writing bullets but
letting the bullets always start with
one two three words that serve as a
little sub header for the bullets
because now everyone when they read
these bullets they don't even need to
read it word by word but just by reading
one or two words they have an idea what
what this is about can decide for
themselves so there are some errors that
they don't even want to read because
it's not so relevant for them but others
that they want to read more about next
let's talk about distributing to do's
distributing the next steps to your team
and an error that i often see and i
think it's often quite dangerous is if
you want that someone in the team does
certain things you just in the middle of
the email somewhere mention their name
right and of course if these people very
carefully read the whole email they
might spot their name and they might
spot here the information that this is
what they need to do but in general i
think it's a good practice that whenever
you want to address someone in an email
and that person is supposed to do
something you bold that name right so in
the middle of the email you make that
name bold because then of course the
person will quite directly see that this
is where you write about the person and
can then also read on the associated to
do's tasks things that you want the
person to do let's talk about two
additional tips that are maybe not
directly related to this example email
but the first thing that bothers me
quite a lot is this email ping pong that
often happens if you want to schedule a
meeting with someone because what often
happens is that one person proposes
dates then you need to check in your
calendar propose other dates and then
goes back and forth and so to avoid
making this process even more
complicated make it a good habit of
yours that whenever you ask for a
meeting always start with some first
suggestions that you directly share and
of course now there are many more modern
mechanisms with meeting links
schedulings that can speed up this
process even more and the second little
suggestion is to push for action in
these emails because often you have the
bit unpleasant situation that maybe you
ask a question or waiting for feedback
and the people aren't replying you don't
know do they still have a point to share
or not and so on and a little technique
that i found often quite effective is to
always then mix your emails with little
deadlines right so maybe write something
in the end so if you have any feedback
on that or any other point you want to
add please let us know until tomorrow or
2pm and if you don't hear anything from
them until tomorrow 2 pm then you let
them know that you assume that this
email is all right now all that being
said we all know that the number of
emails that is written in many
professional jobs is far too high the
number of emails we receive can really
be overwhelming so let me share three
tips on what some things are that you
should avoid when not to write an email
and i think the first is whenever you
just want to share one or two lines a
casual thought nothing that needs to be
forwarded needs to be acted on rather
void emails right many companies have
solutions like microsoft teams slack
google chat and similar solutions in
place rather use them and rather don't
write an email when it's not absolutely
necessary second to be careful when you
want to use emails to escalate things we
all know this feeling something bothers
you a little bit angry so let's write an
email put lots of people on cc and
complain so of course these are often
also political games and i don't want to
say that this is always the wrong thing
to do but just one tip of advice that
actually i picked up from a high school
teacher back in the day is that that
person told me you know when you are
angry when you really just want to say
something to someone when you want to
write such a message
sleep over it for one night just take a
break sleep over it for one night if the
next day you still feel like that this
is the right thing to do then go for it
but often the next day you see things
far different you feel different about
it and then you might even regret having
written such an email the last day and
then third a tip i picked up from a
partner i used to work with that person
once told me
good news in writing
bad news in person right so if you have
a good news to share something great
that maybe you did or your team achieved
write an email about that why well
because you want to make it permanent
because you want to give the recipient
the opportunity potentially to forward
the good news to other people share the
good message and then this of course
will be something that will often be
positive for you on the other hand avoid
putting bad news in writing maybe you
did a mistake you need to come clean on
it for these things don't write an email
whenever possible pick up the phone have
a face-to-face conversation with the
person you want to talk to and here for
the very same reasons you don't want to
make it too easy for that person just to
forward the email to other people making
it very salient what you did what went
wrong you don't want the person half a
year later in their email inbox search
for your name and then just by chance
finding this email again reminding them
of the things that maybe went badly the
things that you did wrong in the past so
of course this might be a little bit
oversimplified for some situations but
in general the rule of thumb is good
news in writing bad news in person so do
you have any other tips on how to write
effective emails just leave a comment in
the comment section big big thanks to
all the members of firm learning for
making a contribution much appreciated
if you took any value out of this video
at all please destroy the like button
for the youtube algorithm and also
subscribe and turn on the notification
bell my name is heinrich you release
videos every single saturday see you
here again on this channel next week
until then all the best to you and bye